[Music]
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
five billion easy
but it's just a story i beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot he almost got me killed
clockwise sully well it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly
but the voyage was not just about gold
or something much more valuable this
cross has a very tragic history so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
[Applause]
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
well you know my brother said
you have no idea who you partnered with
what else aren't you telling me
the victor
spoils
how are they gonna get them out of here
wow
[Music]
hey put them down boys
what is that thing on your face all
right puberty's right around the corner
kid you can grow your own
in movie theaters